[Musique]
x
la table au milieu comme d'habitude oui
[Musique]
car ça nous fait du bien un peu mais je
me rince là mais partout pas dû dire à
jacques sérieux il n'y a rien qui tarit
bla enfin bon ça magique et d'image mais
prendra le risotto vouvray leur côté
fusil comme d'habitude pardon non notre
cote comme d'habitude non la dérision de
pouvoir monsieur nous on va savoir je
vous laisse je vais plus parler de ça
chez nous
j'ai pas envie de venir se frotter les
nichons sur moi une petite pipe comme
d'habitude suivant le bronze comme
d'habitude se regardent jamais pu
supporter il affole déjà la soirée c'est
pas gentil pour une fois pendant six
blocs est terminé et c'est toi t'es
bizarre et staff m'a dit c'est bon tu
vas rentrer
[Musique]
je n'accomplirai messages appelaient
ouais parce que ta nouvelle poupe
bonjour mademoiselle impérativement vous
êtes qui en fait tu me reconnais plus tu
vas petit chez evans est l'art du couple
viguier les promesses et les premières
ce que tu m'as fait là
en volley c'est ça témoin excusez moi
vous sortez en fait on m'excusera qu'il
ya un public voilà monsieur jean marie
bigard est un menteur merci les
promesses samedi
c'est bon vous sentez vous présentais
wazen pourquoi le sort de nulle part et
il est plus sain portuaire sais que nash
les ont fait du mal
ce soir c'est bizarre quand même temps
et un autre comédien qui voudraient
parler non non je suis dans ses pompes
les chants textes en sortir avec ça ne
peut pas vraiment rigolé en fait puisque
cette mafia ne sort pas de nulle part
choses si ce nom mais moi je crois que j
groupe russe qui s'est passé on a
comment une personne qui tient depuis
maintenant à peu près un mois qui vous
ressemble vraiment ouais qui s'est passé
pour vous et landon 1800 euros
d'accord donc à très bien la relance
[Musique]
sur le compte des mois je pensais que
c'était pourquoi
non mais attendez il doit s'achever fin
tu es vraiment je suis vraiment désolé
mais ça oui non mais ces moyens vous
laisse jouer merci merci jalousie à
chevelure et tous les gars
[Musique]
c'est le mec est un téléphone tout à
l'heure
zeromus [ __ ] la sanema petit toit du
coup tu rigoles des gardes tu payes à
kano à voir également la la tête et
quito du coup oui sans doute mais c'est
bien tu fais en club on souffre de
problèmes
kenza appelle la police appelle pour des
faits la police dit dont la police fasse
ou dise que je ne te bûcher c'est que
maintenant il ya une femme policier
c'est génial ce qui pouvait donner c'est
bien drôle
vous aimez vous pas ce qu'ont déjà
monsieur jeu
il était temps que j'étais bien la
vérité je veux savoir dieu qui doivent
1800 euros
monsieur viguier viennent plus à moi et
moi je les reconnais plus là donc je
sais plus j'ai écouté je veux même pas
savoir faire je viens de comprendre ce
qui se passe très bien au québec chez
moi je veux savoir monsieur voilà s'il
vous plaît il va me dire qu'elle est
fausse
monsieur morandini le carreau j' ai dit
quoi le seul nom de collège suivi pour
les yeux a bien joué elle sort pas du
portefeuille de mon mari cette cassure
de monde que je vois moi j'ai vraiment
nous en sortir
[Musique]
c'est parti voilà ce qui motive il va la
pêche rue des glacis fait un trou est
creusé creusé creusé creusé à main
ils entendent il entend une voix est
belle et qui comme ça
il n'y a pas de poisson ici et qui c'est
qui me parle c'est le directeur de la
patinoire
[Applaudissements]
allez-y monsieur ancenis alors on aime
sûr j'ai ça le mec qui dit son médecin
du docteur je crois que j'ai besoin
d'eux
de lunettes et le muguet dit je vous le
confirme pas ce que c'est une banque qui
si elle c'est bon temps en temps on va
emmener monsieur au commissariat la
vérité est dans le siba je vais vous
montrer c'est tout de suite à quoi le
problème
gbagbo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]